so welcome for joining us we're really
excited to have you here
I want to let everyone know that Renee
is now in her second week of fun
employment as we like to call it so we
just want to welcome you to that life
stage we know a lot about it I'm retired
so Burleigh starting there
I'm just curious after 30 years at Intel
what was it like the the morning you
woke up and you knew you were gonna
leave yeah that's a great question I
don't know that it was one morning and I
apologize I don't wanna have my back to
these people I think it was a journey of
a couple of things I mean I think
everyone in the audience probably knows
that I was a candidate to be CEO and I
was not selected for for co-ceo which
was the proposal we made but to become
president so I think that was the first
you know I actually at the time was
thrilled and I still you know loved the
company so much I was so excited to
serve in that capacity but I would I
didn't realize three years ago is that I
really did want to be the leader of my
own company and that became more clear
to me through the core through the
journey of the you know the two and a
half years up into the point I decided
to resign that I really wanted to be in
charge and it turns out you know you you
kind of get to this point in your career
where it's like and being in charge
isn't so much about being the boss it's
more about setting the strategy and you
know and creating the leadership
environment that you want and making the
decisions around how you're going to
handle things that are more difficult in
a certain way and and so I kind of I
think it was kind of in the background
but there were a series of events that
occurred where I would have made
different decisions and I realized at
that point that it was time for me to go
because I had a different point of view
about what was possible for the company
and the path that I would take to get
there and you know
I think everybody knows I worked for
Andy forever and that he's still my
mentor and he would say if you ever get
to the point where you no longer agree
with the strategy what are you doing so
I said what am i doing that was either
the bravest thing that anyone's ever
done or the stupidest we're still gonna
figure that part out I know you know it
I'm not I did my exit interview last
Monday morning and the head of human
resources who's worked for me for I
don't know 18 years had to do the exit
and I told him in advance that you know
six months ago I said you know Matt
you're gonna get me to get ready for
this this is gonna be very emotional for
you
we're gonna talk about you I said no
we're not because I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna be okay in that meeting it's gonna
be you and it we weren't exactly the way
I thought they all came in and they were
all upset and are you still going to
take our phone calls and she's okay
really I kind of go cuz I'm retired now
yeah it was hard it's still hard right I
love Intel and I think Intel has
incredible possibilities but I would
take a different journey so let's talk
about that you mentioned having a
difference of opinion on the strategy
for Intel in case the audience doesn't
know a few instances in your career this
came up prior so you had the early idea
of Intel housing outsource servers first
of all businesses well before Amazon and
others were doing that the bust of 2001
sort of led them to move away from that
strategy later on you tried to guide
Intel towards a to be an early adopter
of a mobile strategy that again was this
initiative that was not successful talk
to us about what it's like to have that
vision and some of the difficulties of
shifting a behemoth like Intel towards
achieving it yeah I think the first
there kind of two different situations
the first one was a kind of an
acknowledgement about how
would want to consume technology over
the horizon and as Andy says to be well
you were absolutely a hundred percent
directionally correct just a decade too
soon which is the same as being wrong so
that was his polite way of saying it
blew it
although he by the way was the one who
he and Craig gave us way too much money
for that endeavor but so that that was a
different situation that was a situation
of making what I would call managerial
or more junior managerial mistakes was
my first senior management job
I wrote a business plan that asked for a
lot of money you know a hundred million
dollars a lot of money they gave me
three hundred and fifty million okay so
when somebody gives you way more money
than you ask for what's the first thing
that you say you're in this Graduate
School of Business at Stanford so let's
hear it no thank you no thank you I
don't need that much money because if
you take it they want to return so you
don't want to take more money than your
business plan until you actually know or
hit the milestone at which you need it
so when people want to over finance you
because they think you're a little
unicorn you say no thank you I'll be
back and after I prove to you I've made
this milestone okay that's like your
little tip of the day it's so of course
said oh my gosh 350 million dollars
that's a lot of money think of all the
things I could build which it did and
then I got to lay all those people off
so I think you know that was a learning
experience on two sides one I didn't
know enough to say to stick to my plan
and on the other side of it I wasn't a
senior enough manager to convince the
then CEO that we should stick it out in
a smaller capacity like downscale and
then stick it out through the downturn
he just lost faith and decided to sell
it off so that's Teradata but the second
one is a completely different situation
this is a situation where I was a senior
manager at the time I mean I was
executive vice president company and the
CEO and I disagreed and he's the boss
and I think that I did the right thing
for our shareholders and I think it was
the right strategy for the company
and I think we'd be a very different
company if we had been able to pull it
off and Brian and I tried but it was you
know four years or maybe five Robert
Roberts in the case about it later
there's a case about this and we lost
too much momentum you know arm has had
two billion units in the field and was
shipping almost two billion a year now
new and at a certain point in in my
industry in any industry when you have a
platform once you get you know a network
effect going it's just too late and I
think that was the case but that was a
case where you had to decide what you
believed and you had to stand up for
yourself at risk of political risk in
and I think that's very dangerous and I
think you have to know what's at play
and so I of course did what I always do
I went and talked to people who advised
me through my career you need mentors
like this mentor thing is real you
really do need Mentors
and I remember that and II said to me
you know this is one of those situations
where if it doesn't go well you might
have to leave and I said yeah he said
but you know you should do what you
believe if you think you're really right
but yeah that's not helpful okay no but
you know I knew mobile was right and I
believed it I was on the board of
Vodafone I could see the data
I understood Paul's position we had a
franchise that generates cash that
people dream about you know and you
don't want to disrupt that and pricing
coming in below that is a huge you know
compression to your pricing but it's
also was consistent with the philosophy
of the company which was to always be a
first mover and embracing that which is
going to disrupt you right so it was a
typical Christensen situation seemed
pretty strategically straightforward and
we couldn't execute it and then why
couldn't we execute it it why why
because people do what they think the
CEO wants even if they know it's wrong
that's what I learned and that's a very
dangerous phenomena but people want to
please in a lot of large large companies
although I see it in startups - are very
hierarchical and so they're like hey
this is what the boss wants and we hear
you Renee and we know you're right and
and and we want to do that and we would
do it and we would start but our hearts
weren't in it and then when we had an
resource allocator it all comes down to
money right or resources people money
when you have a resource allocation
conflict it always goes the other way
because you know that's what the boss
wants
yeah yeah so you mentioned Andy and you
mentioned mentorship you started it
Intel 28 years ago my dad as a technical
I was a lot younger as a technical
assistant to Andy Grove who is sort of a
Silicon Valley great that wasn't my
first job but it was right at the you
know kind of the seven-year mark in my
career okay and so he he was famous for
his confrontational nature he liked to
call it constructive confrontation what
did you learn while you were working so
closely with him and how did that inform
how you decided to manage when you got
to the president role and throughout the
rest of your career at Intel well I
think you know Andy had a couple of
pieces of advice that he didn't always
follow but that were actually very very
important I mean we don't always all
aren't self consistent but one of them
was to watch what people do not what
they say and he used to say you know
we'd be negotiating a partnership or an
employee would be giving a presentation
and they'd say yeah you hear what
they're saying but what are they really
doing because whatever people are really
doing that's actually their strategy
right not what they're saying so I have
used that technique I can't I mean it
probably almost every day right III read
what people are gonna say to me and then
I wanna figure out what have they
actually been doing whatever what's the
real action if they're consistent then
you know you have one point of view and
if they're not you know the other one is
clarity imperative I think this is
really important Andy used to be
ruthless and one of my first I love this
story so I'm you know all of I don't
know 28 years old or something and I go
into this meeting and the guy comes down
and he's got all these and he's gonna
pitch for a new networking business we
were
networking probably four times and he's
begins pitching but he's actually
talking about something different and
he's like that's not the topic of this
meeting and he's like well ya know I
heard this don't disturb avoid one of
your classes because ya know that's not
what we're here to discuss you're not
being clear
you don't have your act together and he
said the meetings over he got up and
walked out there's a roomful of people
I'm like oh that's kind of cool
so but you know the clearer the clarity
imperative is you know really knowing
what it is that matters and you know
being able to write it down in five
slides like the five slide test actually
is hard yeah and I think that's one of
the things that he really forced he
forced intellectual rigor and clarity
and that is something that has really
been defining of my leadership style
because I will tend to find the thing
that somebody is either hiding or not
saying and go after it and that is so
Andy and I'll find it
like in a millisecond I used to take me
longer but now not so much and I'll go
and as soon as I find it I know there's
something there and there's something
they're not telling me and there's a
reason they're not telling you and
whatever that is that's what's really
going on
very interesting happened you know I
just bought I just told you the story in
there and the greenroom I just joined
the board of City and the CFO came in
and he was talking about all these
things and I quit overweight and he
skipped over something that I mean you
know in the normal course of managing
corporate finance of a company of scale
cities about the same sizes Intel you
would ask the following basic things and
so of course I just asked the question
he glossed over I made him go back twice
and I knew there was something there
so okay in terms of talking about
getting on boards and thinking about how
you analyze what's there versus maybe
what's being unsaid you have said that
you want to take on a CEO CEO role
somewhere what's your process for
deciding what exactly you're looking for
that is a great question so my process
isn't very good
and my mentor explained to me that I
really really sucked at this I made a
list of the things I didn't want to do
because because I decided that that you
know I could do so many things and I was
interested in so many things and I
really love my work at Vodafone for
example and that's completely different
than running a semiconductor company and
I find city very challenging and FinTech
in the what's gonna happen you know like
and really interested in that so then I
said okay but what are the things that
really I don't want to ever do again so
my first the top my list my list test
right now it has three maybe four things
on it first no bad boards because at the
other day when you're CEO it's all about
the board if you have a dysfunctional
board and a board that you don't you
know that isn't supportive or that has
their own internal dynamic and politics
like that's just life's too short for
that
no bad boards no bad bosses well
actually don't really want a boss every
year I kind of I kind of and and you
know I want to do something that matters
because there's lots of stuff that you
can do there's lots of work in the world
but at this point for me I want to do
something that really contributes and
changes you know that matters there are
something big changes in front of us
that I think you know I could go work on
I have considered starting my own
company I'm a scale operator that's what
I am I know that I've voluntarily
advised startups and venture backed and
you know and I can give them advice but
I'm definitely a scale operator so I've
thought a lot about starting my own but
you know that's 24/7 365 which I've done
for 28 years so I decided not to make
any of those decisions and to take a
short break which has been one week long
I think I should get a job
woke up this morning and I thought thank
God I have to go to Stanford today at
least I have a reason to get dressed
wake up at 5:30 and I read my mail which
now only takes me about 15 minutes and
then I read all the news and now it's
6:15 that I work out and I have
elementary school children yeah that's a
whole nother topic so I can drive them
to school which I find fascinating and I
also learned something important you can
make any job stressful okay so
permanently driving the carpool can be
very stressful for me but for others
like seriously we're not solving world
hunger here ladies let's just move on so
how is your family factoring into your
decision
well I the reason one of the reasons
that I decided I should take at least
more than a week off is my older son is
looking at colleges so we're doing the
college to her thing and I'm getting him
ready to go off to college or apply to
college next year so it's factoring in
but my kids are worried they're like mom
seriously you're a really high energy
like girl so I did I have way too many
boards I have four boards right now
everyone's like are you gonna be a
professional director I'm like I want to
say no I'm not but I think I am right
now but not forever I mean because I do
want to stay active and yeah I'm just
you know most of the jobs that are you
know for CEOs if you're not it on I I'm
an entrepreneur but I'm a large-scale
entrepreneur our mid-cap and mid-cap
might not work for me because like
having one product in six hundred
million dollars of revenue is like not
my sweet spot yeah I'm more kind of in
the 70-200 because you know when I
started looking at balance sheet of City
right and that I mean those numbers like
when they talk about things they're
talking about you know multiple
trillions it always move in a day and
you know the billion dollars this way
and that way and that's like kind of the
scale of Intel it's kind of the scale of
Vodafone it's kind of the scale of
Oracle so that's kind of the mentality
that I operated and I think what happens
even if you shift jobs a lot is you kind
of develop skills in certain areas and
you have a certain kind of capability
and
you know talking about scale on the
level that you're talking about scale
and then talking about being an
entrepreneur a lot of times those things
are very much at odds how do you or you
know actually I think I have a quote
from you right here that says we have a
tolerance for risk taking we have a
tolerance for taking measured risks and
betting it's not a tolerance for failure
as an entrepreneur how do you think
about that how do you sort of rectify
and what does that really mean well I
think at the scale that we take risks or
I've taken risks and I have failed and
we do fail I mean everybody who takes
risks fails failures part of taking
risks right and you do have to have a
tolerance for failure so that's probably
not really accurate that I said that as
I was wrong I mean you really have to be
able to fail you have to be measured
though and I think one of the things
that I would say is that in a large
entity you can take bigger risks but you
have to ring-fence you know kind of what
what's the downside and so I do tend to
you know understand like how much are we
willing to really lose how much how long
could we really sustain this you know
you need to know those things because
large entities have very low tolerance
for loss very low tolerance in general
and so I think that's one of the things
that works against entrepreneurship it's
very unusual that you end up in Google
right or even Oracle I mean they're
transforming this company to be a cloud
company at risk of a licensed business
that's prints money right so but but
that'll mean that will make them a
bigger and greater company and sustain
them the next couple of decades so it's
really one of these things where you
have to understand you know what your
tolerance is and large companies just
don't have that much tolerance and
that's why they start stuff and stop
stuff and start stuff and stuff so my
biggest criticism of Intel is that we
always quit stuff right before we could
have
you know yeah you look at a company like
Mellanox the company you cannot even
afford to buy many of you probably don't
know this it was a company that was X
and tell people who took technology that
Intel quit on right yeah just fine
thanks I mean there's tons of them I
mean they're all they're littered
throughout tech yeah things that we gave
up on you live in datacenter yeah what I
hear a lot of in that that response is
that you really knew Intel you had a
28-year career there you had gone
through different divisions you were
sort of a subject matter expert on Intel
and it's tolerance for risk taking among
many of its personality and it company
right and it's personality and its
culture do you feel any insecurities
about stepping into a new role where you
won't have 28 years with the company and
you won't you won't be a subject matter
expert in that respect you know I think
I did for a long time I don't know and
but I did and I think that kept me from
ever leaving for a long time I think
that's why people stay at companies so
long you know they love the work they
know the situation well and all the
things they don't like they know what
they're about right I I don't have that
fear anymore because I think one of the
things that if you step back from the
day-to-day there's a lot of pattern
recognition in the behaviors of
companies different sizes and
irrespective of the content a lot of the
same challenges and opportunities exist
you know about consolidations in the
market about you know whatever whatever
was going on in the competitive and you
can actually apply I mean working in
semiconductors has nothing to do with
banking and I've been at the bank for
the last couple of weeks being
indoctrinated and I realize wow
pattern recognition there are a lot of
similarities when you have two hundred
thousand employees working in a whole
bunch of geographies having a whole
bunch of you know challenges yeah you
have a regulatory regime that overlays a
competitive environment you're like wow
this is I get this
right I understand some of the in and it
actually has been really exciting like
wow I could do something completely
different although I think banking is
actually a tech business now well you
heard it here first no I mean everybody
knows that right I mean the next billion
people aren't gonna go open bank
accounts yeah it's a tech business yeah
and so is that that makes it more
appealing to you oh yeah I love it I
think it's fascinating I think the
entire way that the economy's work and
the movement of money and the concept of
crypto currencies and I think fin tech
and what's going to happen in digital
economies it's going to be one of the
most interesting things that are gonna
happen in the next ten years and that
everything we've been doing one of the
things that I realized you know I've
been realizing as I've been on this
journey too you know what comes next is
that everything I've been working on for
the last thirty years is actually
infrastructure like everyone had to have
computers to be able to do any of this
other stuff we had to actually be able
to build computers at a cost that
allowed them to be pervasive and that
all of this I mean I cannot begin to
tell you unless you work in
semiconductors how complicated is to
build semiconductors it is so complex
I mean it's mind-blowing ly complex okay
and dangerous and we build this huge
chemical come you know buildings and
they cost a 7 billion dollars and then
we make these things that are so small
no one can even see them and they want
to pay us like 20 bucks for them that
kind of sucks and at the end of the day
I mean it really does it's a hard
business it is building the framework
for everything that's built on top of it
and everything that built on top of it
now computing is so so powerful and so
pervasive and Mobile is so amazing you
can do it like I mean you do not need to
go in a bank anymore and I think
security and identity the identity thing
I'm just super excited about that
there's so much green space of what's
gonna happen and identity management you
mentioned wanting to do something that
that matters one of our application
genes that we all have to answer when we
come here is what matters most to us and
why what matters to you what falls into
the category of something that matters
what matters to me is making the world a
safer place so the things that I find
myself working on my free jobs my
volunteer jobs are for the government
and in cyber and I think the and even
even even at Citigroup I started working
on there and in money laundering and
there's their cyber team you know I
think the ability to know what's safe
and good is going to become even more
and more important to people you know in
a world that's less physical right and I
think that's that's a very important
frontier because we have not made a lot
of not fundamental breakthroughs we're
really in good in detection and repair
we're not really good in prevent and
we're not really really good in Identity
Management so known good yeah right how
do you think about that in terms of you
said those have been volunteer roles and
you have them we were appointed by
President Obama to help out with some of
the critical infrastructure work how do
you make the decision between what is
going to be sort of a side service
project and what's going to be one of
the main tenants of your career well I
think you know I used to think people
would always say this they say this all
the time well you should follow your
passion and money will fall and always
thought that's just crap that doesn't
really happen but it turns out it might
be right I mean maybe I was wrong about
it because I keep drifting towards the
same kind of projects and even as I got
onto the board of Citi that's the first
thing that I started to get involved in
so I think that that's my passion so I
think it's going to become the primary
right because I really I really think
it's important work and it's not getting
done and there's you know there's a lot
of small companies doing bits and pieces
of it when the problems insecurity and
the problem I attempted to go after
inside of Intel maybe that was a mistake
and should have done it outside of Intel
is to actually consolidate into a
platform
there's no security platform you know
how you guys are mostly well not
everybody's too young to knows but in
the early days of computing right ever
there's all these like little weird
things and different applications and
the Microsoft think the Lord put it all
together into a platform for us and as
much as we'd like to bitching complain
about them they changed the world yeah
the same way that Google did for you
know application development mcleod
right now Amazon's doing for services so
those platforms are quite important
because what they do is they move the
entire industry forward to a place where
a whole bunch of innovation comes on top
of it so that's what's happening Amazon
Amazon is the new great infrastructure
kind of like Intel was in in the 80s and
90s right building the base
infrastructure so I think it's security
that hasn't happened there's no but
there's no galvanizing like way to think
about how to put all this stuff together
there's different point solutions so
that's a piece of work that needs to be
done so while you were at Intel you were
the head of Intel's diversity initiative
the company pledged three hundred
million dollars to recruiting and
retaining more minorities and women
within the company was that something
you drifted to or was that something you
sought out that is a great question the
answer is I did not drift to it it
reported to me and I embraced it
wholeheartedly at a point in my career
where I thought that by me lending
myself to it it would make it more
viable up until the point that I was the
president company I would say they had
to beg me to do women's initiatives I
hate him I do I think a bunch of woman
talking to themselves about how things
are does nothing so I think one of the
things that was you know my big
achievement was to get a whole bunch of
been involved the he for she thing
that's going on
intel has the kind of the version of
that which is internal you know the men
involved in having you know group
dialogue about diversity and diversity
is beyond women it's you know everyone
you know and we weren't doing a good job
with that so I think we were able to do
a broader job into
I was able to lend my my position
authority to make it you know really get
legs inside the company and to some
extent outside the company and so I was
excited and passionate about that I have
a very strong sense of justice which is
probably why I'm so attracted to you
know the defense of you know cybercrime
right and I don't like that there you
know prior to this year we were we would
publish data that would say that you
know women didn't make as much you spend
now that's been fixed so that's a
fabulous accomplishment we just release
the data last week but there's so much
work to be done you know I'm happy that
we're having a dialogue I'm happy to see
there's a dialogue about it at City
there's a dialogue about it Vodafone
there's a dialogue about it everywhere
that's great but you know it's a lot of
work it's not done in one year so I'll
give you another quote from from this
time your mentor Andy Grove goodness he
said that kind of puts hair on your
chest to do that and survive as a woman
in software in a company that's a
manufacturing company to do that you
have to have strength as a woman at
Intel what was it to put hair on your
chest
I'm trying to decide where to go with
that so many think showing up for work
every day you know when I started Intel
which was a complete fluke I was working
at a startup that Intel acquired and my
family I grew up in Silicon Valley my
dad worked at HP all my friends parents
worked at Intel I was like yeah I am so
not working at that old man company is
not happening but the Intel POTUS and
then you know I was like 22 years old
and I had no money and I wanted to get
my masters so I'm like I'm gonna have to
work there for a while and I went into
it with no idea like I didn't like apply
to Intel and want to work for Intel and
like build semiconductors and I had no
idea like what the semiconductor
industry was really like so I was
blissfully naive for about 10 years and
then one day I I got this review and you
know how employees aren't supposed to
talk about their pay with other
employees like that's against the rules
at all companies except they all do it
right so then I found out that I made
way less than all the guys well Mike
wait a minute whoa whoa wait a minute so
I went and asked my boss who was a
legendary guy who works in this valley
and I said well I am I being paid less
because I have the same amount of
experience and I have a master's degree
and they don't and I managed more people
my projects really successful and he's
like you'd probably make as much money
as you deserve to make and I thought
holy [ __ ]
so what did I do what are you doing that
happened you call your mother so I
called my mother I said what do you
think he's saying she says I think he's
saying cuz you're a girl you don't get
to make as much and I said that sounds
wrong my mother's like it is do
something so you know my mother my
mother was the first Santa Clara County
Sheriff a woman so I called her and you
know my gun-toting Sheriff mother she
said outcry you should call it if
they'll see so I got a chart I say this
is typical Renee I said I think there's
something wrong with the data and
they're like no there's we can't show
you that data but you have to you have
to prove to me that I make the same
amount
as as the men and so this was the
beginning of a journey where I fought
the system I fought the whole time and I
didn't realize I fought the whole time
till the day I quit and I was sitting
there and I was thinking to myself god
I'm tired 28 years because I thought the
system the whole time a system that was
resurrected in an old model that Brian
and I and I think Brian's doing an
outstanding job here has revolutionized
you know the culture of Intel he's
working so hard on that and I give him a
lot of credit for that because that was
really hard but my god
you know 28 years ago can you imagine
yeah and I was the only one so then I
got into this habit this came out of
this dumb review every meeting for like
a decade I'd write in the corner how the
men to woman ratios it'd be like 28 to
125 to 1 so this went on for a really
long time and so I think what really
made me the person I am today is I
fought for equality from the day I got
there and every single year HR would be
like oh god here she comes again I'll
make him show me the data and if anyone
eats ahead of me and they didn't get as
good a review as me that was it that was
it I laid down the law I'm like I never
got a promotion I didn't ask for exactly
well so you mentioned Brian in that in
that comment and you guys were touted
when you when you came on to be a you as
president he is CEO management team has
had complementary skill sets yep but
that was the first for Intel the the
dual team can you talk was the first to
appoint the dual team together but it
wasn't the first dual team right okay
well yeah that's right yeah because
because well I want to correct that
because Gordon and Andy were a team for
1718 years Andy was president and CEO
and Gordon was the CEO and chairman and
then Andy and Craig were in the same
city Paul did not have a partner for
eight years so there's an 8 year gap and
then they appointed both of us at the
same time which was so how'd the board
come to that decision and what are some
of the advantages and
disadvantages of the co-leadership team
well I'm a fan of co-leadership I still
am and even though I decided I wanted to
go lead on my own I'm a fan of
co-leadership
and I would have a co-leader I think it
works really well at Oracle it's working
very well there it these jobs are too
big for one person when you have two
hundred plus thousand people I mean but
City has a co leadership they have a CEO
and they have a president you just need
someone to be doing some of the other
stuff right I mean just these are just
big jobs so I'm a fan of that I think
that when you have complementary skills
that's fabulous
Bryan and I do I think the comp the
complexity between Bryan and I was that
I have always been a strategist and a
market facing externally you know doing
partnerships building businesses running
piell's and Bryan had been very
internally facing facing a CEO and we
really were in role reversal and I think
that was one of the more complex
dynamics for us because Bryan needed to
learn you know how to develop and lead a
corporate strategy and that's an
uncomfortable thing for the CEO to have
the president be more adept at that
which is the primary job of the CEO and
I do think to be fair to Bryan he was
extraordinarily you know gracious and
letting me set a lot of the strategy and
do things but a certain point in his
tenure he needs to run the company he's
the CEO and that's the decision the
board made and that was the point at
which I said look your this is your job
brand you're the one who's going to you
know die or live on the decisions if you
want to go this direction go but I don't
agree but you get to decide your CEO so
I shouldn't work here anymore and I'm as
painful as that conversation was it was
the right one and I think very adult
right because he needed to set the
strategy it was time for him to do that
I mean that was the complexity of our
particular situation is that I was more
skilled to be a CEO that a second is
that a conversation you you wish you had
had
earlier in your partnership no I
actually think it went exactly as it
should have gone because they think at
the point we were at if Intel had been
led by an external person for the first
time the history company it probably
would've been certain death company was
a huge inflection there was a lot of
unrest about what direction to do what
you know we had to do some lot of
changes that aren't really apparent to
you guys but we had to do a lot of
cultural changes around comp and fits
and just a lot of stuff that hadn't been
dealt with for a while
so I think the right thing for the
company was stability I think the right
thing for the company was continuity and
Brian's brought a lot of change and he's
on his path you know with what he wants
to do with IOT and I think that's
fabulous so I think we have time now for
questions we'll start with one question
from Twitter and then we'll head out to
the audience so please please be sure to
raise your hands if you have a question
and they'll find you up and down the
aisles wonderful insights and great
banter which I always a fan of and so
that the first question that comes
through is asking you know you've been
in Silicon Valley your whole life if you
could change one thing about it be its
culture attitude interest whatever what
would it be
Wow first of all I should say I love it
here I love the valley there's not a lot
I would change except I I would I would
like it to be a little bit I'd like the
diversity discussion to be more serious
in the sense that we got more traction
it's one thing for big public companies
to do work on diversity but you know the
predominance of the employment around
this valley is not big huge companies
anymore it's mid caps and and
entrepreneurial people like to move
around a lot and I still think the
diversity issue plagues Silicon Valley I
I cannot tell you how much time I spend
advising or or spending time with really
wonderful companies still largely LED
and financed by men
hi there thanks so much for taking my
question you mentioned briefly that
you've never received a promotion that
you didn't ask for can you just
elaborate on that a bit well so this is
fascinating and true and turns out has
been true and I mean I'm on a lot of
compensation committees so in addition
to Intel right and see this over and
over again I am as I admitted not the
kind of big women's person but I'm gonna
sound like I am at these comments but
anyway women tend to not apply for jobs
unless they can hit every single
criteria and think they're perfect at it
so what happens is in interviews women
will come in and they will tell us the
ten percent of the things that they are
not good at so therefore they're not
good enough for the job their male
counterparts will come in and there'll
be ten percent qualified for the job and
they'll tell us all the reasons we
should hire them anyway and this happens
in every company that I'm involved with
and they're all you know big
multinational companies and so the same
thing happens with promotions I managed
in a company of men
I managed men for 28 years and some
women thankfully but not that many and
they are always asked for promotion like
every year at their at the review you've
not gonna get promoted every year but
every year I got asked for and in every
women never asked for promotion now I am
an outlier
I just behaved like my peers all I did
was behave like all the guys that I
worked with and it worked out really
great but I I don't know what that is
it's a cultural thing we see it
everywhere it's in all of the diversity
data if you read anything online
it's it'll tell you about this phenomena
so I think one of the things you just
have to get comfortable with this
understanding that people asked to be
promoted they do and then asking to be
promoted you get an idea about what
their aspirations are and you tell them
what they need to do to be promoted and
then if they actually do it you're
better for us as a leader in our company
cuz you've gotten a whole bunch of
output and then you get to promote them
you don't get that same dialogue usually
so I think that's that's the thing that
I always did I'm sure I was super
annoying I'm really sure I was
Thank You Reni for taking my question I
would like to thank you because I work
for software solutions group at Intel Oh
under your leadership I came in through
the diversity that I just loved Intel so
thank you so much my question is how
many more decades would the Moore's law
still be true how how fast do you think
Moore's law is as well alive and well
and as I no longer work it until I'm not
in a position to comment beyond that but
I will say that it is it is absolutely
fine that is the least of the worries
the things that everyone know that
Moore's law so Moore's law is the
ability to you know create more
performance every couple of years more
in a smaller transistor package and and
or in a denser lithography so people
talk about going from 28 nanometers to
you know 10 nanometers or this or that
and it's very technical and exciting but
the fact is what it's done is it's
allowed us to sequence the human genome
in a you know a few days versus a year
and it's allowed us to find unique
treatments for cancer at the night
Cancer Institute in Oregon as a result
of being able to build basically what it
10 years ago would have been a roomful
of supercomputers on a single chip and
that's that's the the benefit of Moore's
Law and it's what fuels the entire you
know kind of digital economy including
self-driving cars which require massive
amounts of compute power and you know
some of the bigger breakthroughs I mean
even in cyber and personal identity of
them there's a lot about algorithmic
profiling so a lot of that requires just
tremendous amount of compute that we
didn't have available to us and the
Moore's Law has delivered that to us in
the last decade and will continue and
that's why I say Intel has been a
fundamental infrastructure company right
because what they're doing is building
you know kind of the blocks upon which
Tesla will make you know a self
self-driving car or Google or whomever
Hilary Nate and the former you know
employee work at LTP
thanks for all these people my question
will be but culture I see there in in
Oregon the logic technology development
department for a few years and I found
this a hardware culture you know about
chip manufacturing we value creativity
by the same time we value more or at
least equally discipline and execution
do you find that culture is somehow you
know separated from this more of a
software culture like Google you know
Facebook uber we totally evaluate person
or individual individual creativity you
find that all is part of Intel's current
situation I mean your years of yeah I
don't think that any company that gets
to the scale of Google doesn't value
discipline and execution I think at a
certain point in the lifecycle of any
company you get to the point where it
doesn't matter what you're doing
discipline and execution is critical to
the result and so I think Intel is not
unique I mean if you were building car
batteries you'd be in the same situation
as semiconductors right very similar
technology and that discipline and
execution comes from Health and Safety I
find a very similar culture of
discipline execution over content
excitement you know about new innovation
at say Vodafone because Health and
Safety is you know kind of over rules
sometimes innovation so you get excited
about something but it might inject some
kind of risk into the health and safety
so when you build things that people die
building right which you know when you
are putting up a mobile tower people
fall off them unfortunately or they
electrocute themselves or so when you're
in that kind of a business health and
safety tends to put a process regime or
if in our highly regulated business like
the bag put some it puts a process
regime over innovation and I think
that's a difficulty and I think as a
leader you have to actually set
create a avenue for innovation that's
why you see so many big companies
creating these innovation and you kind
of wonder like if innovation on the side
doesn't really help so it's it's it's
complicated you have to be able to have
a process where the innovation occurs
and you pull it back in all right
because in these companies you get to a
certain point and you just have to have
process it's unfortunate but it's part
of scale thanks for joining us you spoke
about the importance of having good
mentors in your career for many of us
will be going out into the real world
again and with you yes so I'd like to
hear from you best practices on finding
those good mentors and setting the stage
such that they want to invest in you I
think a mentorship is a two-way street
so I think finding a great mentor isn't
so much about finding the person it's
also you know what can you add to that
person as well and so for you know great
mentor I'll give you an example one of
the people that is in my little mentor
circle is this wonderful guy who works
at Google but you know he is
bi-directional mentorship right like
he's like here your I am like LinkedIn
seriously like I have a LinkedIn side
just like your LinkedIn sucks I'm
redoing it so I mean so it's like
bi-directional right I'm coaching him
about you know from a career evolution
perspective and he's moving into
management he's never been a big manager
that kind of thing so I think it has to
be bi-directional so you have to find
someone that you not only can advise you
but that you can actually help them
either by bringing them forward in
technology or that your interests or
whatever when they're not bi-directional
they're a bummer and it's really hard
like the person never wants to give time
with you and you'll find they're like
busy always and it's like a burden right
like they want to say yes to you but
it's like what are they getting out of
it kind of thing so it also if you're an
entrepreneur a lot of people who may
mentor you sometimes will invest with
you and then they get very involved in
helping you be successful I'm gonna take
the last
question we're done land and it has to
do with your MBA sheryl sandberg
recently put out an article saying that
MBAs are not really needed in the tech
industry I promise we will not take
offense but do you agree no ok tell us
why well not because I have one I mean
or that I love to go to the MBA program
here or that I beg Jesper to put a
program together for Intel people or
that I think that education in general
and I think this undergraduate and
graduate teaches you not only frameworks
but tools to think right and I think the
MBA gives you an opportunity for having
had some experience in the world right
and being out there to then come back
and and get frameworks and I talk a lot
about pattern recognition because
leadership is about pattern recognition
it's about seeing multiple patterns
occurring understanding what that
competitive move might be or recognizing
that you've seen this before and what
happened the last time and only through
I think you know understanding the
frameworks of competitive strategy you
know economics those kinds of things you
need to know that and by the way CEOs
should be able to read African balance
sheet and an income statement and know
the difference and if they can't that's
a problem it really it is and so and
there are those that the first time they
ever have to deal with corporate finance
is when they become the CEO and you're
like really because now it's complicated
because the world is flat and you have
to deal with FX and you have to deal
with hedging and you have to and you
might be like what are you talking about
running I'm gonna run like a hundred
million dollar company or ten million
dollar company yeah good luck with that
I mean the economy you're gonna sell to
people all over the world guess what
you're gonna have to deal with tax and
trade because you have to deal with the
tax issues when you sell in all these
places and online tax who that's
super-complicated oh how about safe
harbor so this is the stuff you learned
when you're in an MBA program you learn
about the kind of environment of doing
business and then you have contacts and
even if you don't know something you
know I should probably call a lawyer
about that
you know right or how to set up an
entity in a foreign in a foreign place
so I don't I don't agree with that I
think I think we need we have a whole
generation right now of super smart
people who are at ten year mark in their
career 10 to 12 year mark in their
career who want to be leaders who have
absolutely no skill to be leaders sip
they should all come in the MBA program
because they don't know anything they
all grew up with unicorns and they make
tons of money and they're like oh well
I've done these like five thousand
project and you're like that's great but
you know nothing about all this other
stuff because see the problem is once
you get out of running a project or
being in engineering or being in sales
or being a marketing you have to
actually then just do the boring stuff
which is running the corporation and
that stuff is like a whole different
level of stuff it's not that other stuff
it's that gee I wish people wouldn't sue
me for antitrust that really sucks
be good if you actually knew what
Westlaw was right and I taught it just
at another business school where some
some students didn't understand that
some of the things that we're proposing
we're against the law I mean so you kind
of that's and then you learned that
right you're in a business school class
and they say that's great except that
there's an antitrust law against that
right you can't combine with those
people so Cheryl and I guess we'll have
to disagree on that if everyone would
join me in thanking Renae James